you know you cannot trust the dominator
style not to go psychotic here at the
end I mean they are a have to surround
the place and lay siege to it and the
question is who are they who is it who
has the power to try the dead fingers of
the dominator culture from the
instrumentality of power this is this is
why the chaos which is rising in the
world is it is literally the Gaian fury
it is a moment of opportunity everyone
should understand this that chaos
provides opportunity or commandos of the
new persuasion to rush forward and jam
vital machinery of the Dominator
metaphor so the key the key to correct
political stance in a situation of chaos
is to be alert to opportunity because it
will come the whole thing is advanced
incrementally by people who are always
aware of the possibility that the next
moment will be the one in which to take
a step forward surrender to the Gaian
mind to the to the intuition of the
forward cascade into chaos but never
surrender to to the Dominator metaphor
because it will eventually it's dead
I mean it's death that's unhappiness
it's a neurosis sexual impotence it's
fear of other people it xenophobia it's
all these things
it's psychosis on a mass cultural scale
we have been so long victimized by it
that we're like you know well no that's
almost too harsh but
well what I was going to say was the
kind of culture that we are that we
inherit from the late Roman emergence of
Christian dominance is the kind of
culture that I imagined would come into
existence if the Third Reich had lasted
a thousand years in other words you know
the rough edges get smoothed off but the
the main human suppressing thrust is
kept fully in place and and now it's no
longer a personal or cultural matter
that we are so deeply diseased by this
kind of neurotic conditioning because
the planet itself is at stake the
arsenals that have been piled up the
industrial processes that have been set
in motion there has to be you know and
over a phase transition the cusp must be
just ahead or else we will just script
ourselves out of existence
[Music]
you